direct de la rochelle pour ces
précisions alors en vendée la pluie et
les vents violents ont provoqué une
montée des eaux très rapide conséquence
au moins cinq morts et des communes
inondées arnaud compte en quelques
minutes les rues se sont transformées en
torrents et en crue surpris dans leur
sommeil les habitants ont parfois été
contraint de se barricader chez eux ou
de se réfugier sur les toits en
attendant les pompiers
on s'est levé on a regardé par la
fenêtre on a vu qu'il y avait de l'eau
donc on a prévenu bas tous les voisins
sur les communes situés en front de mer
le niveau de l'eau atteint parfois un
mètre vingt dans la nuit et dans
l'urgence 240 personnes ont été
secourues
le plus souvent porté à dos d'homme
avant d'être mis à l'abri
c'est monté très vite très vite très
très très très vite
en l'espace de quoi un quart d'heure
c'était incroyable on est sorti par la
fenêtre et on a nagé jusqu'à chez des
voisins
hélas tous les meubles flottaient on a
déposé les deux enfants sur un canapé
pour qu'il soit hors de l'eau et nous on
a attendu au fait que les pompiers qui
allie cherchons l'a appelé les pompiers
sont venus chercher j'ai cru à un moment
donné qui avait plus tôt il y avait de
l'eau qui tombait dans la maison de
genre en entendant le bruit de l'eau et
je me suis levé nice en me levant que
j'ai vu qu'il y avait ces cinq
centimètres d'eau particulier
et l'on rentré par les fenêtres par les
ports malgré les nombreux secouristes
déployés sur le terrain la tempête a
fait plusieurs victimes
cinq personnes sont mortes noyées au sud
des sables d'olonne dans un secteur très
localisées sur les communes de
la-faute-sur-mer et de
l'aiguillon-sur-mer un bilan hélas
provisoire
le nombre des victimes n'est absolument
pas estimable pour l'instant puisque ça
augmenté en une heure en était le
premier noyer mais était signalé à 9
heures il est maintenant 10 heures nous
en sommes déjà à cinq corps l'alerté
rouge a été levée ce matin sur la vendée
où 80 % des communes sont privés
d'électricité
et alors là laird